when i was a little boy i would watch
moms maybe like it was a religion
yeah do you think she was the first
stand-up comic i do
i do believe that she was the first i
know she was the first
no no she may have been the absolute
first absolute first yeah
because she's the only one that i know
who actually stood up and told jokes
from really like the late
20s so i sort of feel she might be the
very first stand-up as we know it
yeah so it's extraordinary when you
think about it when was moms maybe born
late 1800s why did you become so
obsessed with moms maybe to the point
that you wanted to make a
a project out of it because i used to do
her before i
uh before anybody gave up to who i was
so how do you go about doing that do you
you first went to hbo
first we went to hbo and they said we're
going to make a documentary we'll make a
documentary and then
then it got a little tough for for them
and us because we had two very different
ways of looking at things what did they
want to do they wanted to do
more of a biopic right and for me there
wasn't you know
the thing about it you see i thought
that when i first
when you first told me you were doing uh
mom's maybelline
i thought you were going to play mom's
maybelline well the whole idea
originally was i was going to do it on
stage
right as a one-person show and then i
would go i would go see that in a second
well i'm still going to do it but howard
i realized that you know i
the last time i did moms was almost 30
years ago in san francisco
did you can you do the impression is it
how it what are you talking about
right you know i can do mom download
your show don't you
and she would kind of walk up maybe
you're right she wasn't really an old
lady but she would dress like an old
lady and she'd have those
like weird shoes big shoes i mean
you know she started this character
figure 1929
1930. right and she was a young woman
then
so mom's was mom's right at 12 at 25.
she was a young woman playing an old
woman playing an old woman and she
when she died in 75 she she had grown
into mom right and you think about it
there were no roles for black actresses
back then unless you were
gone with the wind or something so she
created a role for herself as an old
woman when you think about it
it was really quite brilliant well i
mean the thing that i think she figured
out
was that she had her place and she was
going to rock it
and she did did she have a horrible
personal life moms maybe i know nothing
of you know
today it's so different you know
everything about everyone like i know
who you've married who you
are i know everything with mom's
maybelline you didn't know anything you
didn't know where she came from now
in a way the character worked better
because
you didn't know anything about it did
she have a personal life she had a very
good personal life and there are some
secrets that i'm not going to tell you
on there but
give me one word um let's see
that many of the traumatic stories about
her
may not be true in other words she might
have had a pretty good upbringing
yeah wow and so she embellished
well i think people and what that tends
to happen with performers is people
embellish for you
right you almost don't have to do
anything it's so true yeah
you know and so suddenly she was you
know she had been raped twice
and then she had kids and she gave them
away and so it was this big giant story
that may or may not be true that's why i
didn't want to do a biopic do you get
that in your personal life
they people come up to you who you don't
even know and say whoopi do you remember
when you did this and it it's absolutely
not true
yeah it happens all the time right all
the time yeah with mom's maybelline
though
she was so powerful and now that now
that you're bringing her up i'm thinking
what her life must have been here's this
talented woman
great comic she was born in the wrong
time period
because first of all who would even
imagine that she could even get a career
on stage
well because a black woman we had the
chitlin circuit right
which was where all the black folks went
to perform
because they weren't allowed to perform
in a lot of the clubs
in the rest of the country so there was
a whole area
you know where black people went and saw
performance that they understood and
they knew
and it worked for them because you know
man tan moreland came from there peg leg
baits came from there a lot of the folks
that
that most people don't know about that
was the performance space and that's how
they got to be
better known and tyler perry uh-huh
reawakened that circuit because no one
was making
anything for anything for those for that
group what's weird too is
is that you know it occurs to me
everyone's always asking me who do you
think the funniest comics are and stuff
and i never mentioned mom's maybelline
none of us did and i should like like
she really
she made me laugh till i almost threw up
like i mean i don't laugh that hard at
anybody
and mom's making appointment television
when you heard
that mom's maybelline was gonna be on a
show you sat
there did you get to meet her family uh
when you made this thing
no there's not a lot of folks not a lot
of folks left wow
was she married it's hard to say wow
i know it's a complete mystery in
in a way it is and you identify with her
because
she was one of your heroes because she
was funny and she told
you know it's like richard for me
richard pryor that's my brain
right and moms is my brain because
anybody who can tell
a story and leave space for a punchline
i think is great
right you know she's brave in that she
could literally
take a pause on stage that's right
people said what do you mean brave
i mean when you're in front of a crowd
to take a pause that's right
this silence yes and it scares the [ __ ]
out of you
because you we're so used to feeling
every second
of every moment of every day i mean my
god we can't even go to the bathroom
without the telephone